hey this is presh to Walker here's a fun
little puzzle we have two parallel lines
and a zigzag shape in between the two
parallel lines
the top angle is 40 degrees then we have
80 degrees then we have X and then we
have 20 degrees
the question is to find the value of x
this video went viral on Instagram with
over 14 million views and Counting
I browse the comments and there's
actually widespread confusion over the
correct answer some people think it's 60
degrees others think it's 100 degrees
others think it's 40 degrees other
people even think 80 degrees or 120
degrees or 20 degrees
so once and for all what is the correct
answer to this question
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
so here's how you can work it out the
first thing is to observe that the
diagram is not drawn to scale
this is what an 80 degree angle would
actually look like if it were drawn to
scale
so you should never assume a diagram is
drawn to scale unless it said you can
assume that
but don't worry this won't stop us from
solving the problem
so construct one parallel line through
the vertex of 80 degrees and construct
another parallel line through the vertex
of X degrees
now we have transversals going through
parallel lines so alternate interior
angles are equal to each other
so this angle over here will be equal to
40 degrees
then the next angle will be 80 degrees
minus 40 degrees so this is also equal
to 40 degrees
then we have alternate interior angles
here so this angle will also be equal to
40 degrees finally this angle will be an
alternate interior angle of the 20
degree angle so it will be equal to 20
degrees
therefore X is equal to 40 degrees plus
20 degrees which equals 60 degrees and
that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign